la vie ne m'apprend rien
je voulais juste un peu parlé choisir un
train la vie ne m'apprend rien
j'aimerais tellement m'accrocher prendre
un chemin prendre un chemin ensemble
mais je peux pas je ne sais pas je reste
planté là les lois ne font plus les
hommes et quelques heures me font la loi
mais je ne peux pas je ne sais pas je
laisse le planter là
à la vie de ma provient ou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
je t'écris des beaucoup
j'ai nommé les ratures
et la sueur
j'ai faim
et faute au fur et à
c'est pas de la grand décrété
juste un peu
m
quel
qui se sont envolés
au fur et à mesure
[Musique]
acteur a su
m
avec deux fois rien on peut
aller plus loin
on sera là demain 2
demain
tu vas me
d
au rhdp
décacheté et me déshabille
au fur et à
reçus
au furet
ça
vous
mode je vous dis pas où sont les
toilettes ou la médecine et en tous sens
des deux camps
alors
oh
[Musique]
obama
ewen et campements way
ma mère
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
tél
nhl
de ce fait
qu'est ce
monsieur
je sais je
surfer
c
j'avoue j'en ai bavé pas
[Musique]
mon homme
avant d'avoir eu vent de vous
non
dupuis
s
or dans ce sens là
chaîné nous
bon
une chance
et plus
et c'est plus comme un sage et c'est la
série d'offres
hélas avril au 20 mai
mon amour et ugl
vous
d'avoir une vente de vous parce que
j'aime me rappelle plus des paroles
oh
la nouvelle
c
nous
c'est le
non
un chat
bon
parce que c'est quand il fait très bien
catherine fois il fait très bien
j'entends je viens de gc je sais pas si
on comprend bien pas tu vas voir je sais
même pas si je le fais très bien mûres
fait jouer si jamais nadal risque est
alors c est sa cb crise et ça c'est
comme ça
c'est ce que j'ai pas le nom maintenant
jean pierre je suis et neigé plus de
champagne
je me pense que je vais là moi aussi
parce que tu sais je suis un petit peu
c'est mon sac à dos tout à l'heure c'est
un truc pour les chiens là tu vois ce
que c'est de là qu'est ce que je dois
faire je vais au tour du tout mais moi
je tutoie tu fais ce que tu veux ça on
est pas dans la merde teroma écoute
dîner pour dîner on s'est bien fait chez
soi alors un petit truc qu'on pourrait
sortir un peu faire le tintouin la
grogne qui les bandits dont un a fait
tout est fermé l'oeil et plus taxes y a
plus rien il est 6h30 jésus la mer ah
non
cette situation pour ne rien cacher mes
paroles je suis pas fou et puis bon an
mal an je faisais moment quoi si di
rocco pour ses doigts cause et je peux
pas le dire c'est toi quelle heure
[Applaudissements]
de proposer monsieur là et peu ramé
champignons l'animateur qui démangent
je vais vous prouver une piste
à votre avis fanni est ce que ces
limitations qui donne aux autres le
reflet de ce mois mais n'est ce pas
plutôt le replit soi même par rapport
aux autres qui donne une limite à
écouter fabrice je ne sais pas vraiment
de quoi vous parlez
je ne comprends pas très bien car j'ai
moi même je n'imite personne et j'ai mis
très très mal en tout cas mais je
voulais vous dire j'étais très très
heureuse de vous rencontrer et je rêve
de tourner avec vos audiences bien sûr
mais moi aussi c'est ça qui plaît
c'est pas plus mal je fais pas c'est
bien c'est les et exit les imitateurs
j'adore ça c'est ce que je préfère avec
les vendeurs de merguez son sourire mais
les messieurs n'ont trompé en déviant
des calmes on est bien on a bien regardé
comme on devient donc je dois aussi
pépère tu t'occupes père lui avec
monsieur qui tournent à peu disparu
depuis deux semaines
tiens et aime bien la pelouse
m
[Musique]
oh
m
salut
mais cela
diallo
agathe le 6 mars aux agapes
mais sans eau
photo
oh
il faut ciel a fait le moins à a demandé
gentiment je suis gentil bonjour alors
aujourd'hui dont on ne peut pas plaire à
tout le monde en parle avec 1 guy
carlier 1 également je sais plus si
c'est vraiment jeu ou à tes souhaits ou
si c'est à vue dans quel état non mais
pas du tout c'est pas le rhume des foins
cette fois j l
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux